I'm Matty Matheson and I'm here today to
answer all of your questions from the
internet
Twitter whoo there's a chef support I've
had millions of cookies in my life this
has never happened what is happening am
I looks like you're I don't think
you have enough flour I you probably
don't have any baking powder or baking
soda in there I don't know what recipe
is yeah I think you're kind of that's a
start over
next at Matty Matheson why aren't these
fluffy if you whip egg whites and the
temperature of your batter when you're
adding because you add warm butter
melted butter to the the batter as well
if that's too hot that will kind of
diffuse your whipped egg whites and then
you'll have flat cakes at agrees reason
Dyke what is the sauce exactly is syrup
sauce where do you draw the line Oh
Eddie this is maple syrup this is not a
sauce this is a syrup if I was to take
this and add this to maybe mayonnaise or
if I was to add this to chicken stock
those would become a maple mayonnaise
which would be a sauce or I could add
this to chicken stock reduce that and
make like a chicken maple glaze which is
a sauce so get lost in the sauce get
lost forever my did hatch Okocha
Maddy the American with pickle brine and
buttermilk at the same time if you were
to take buttermilk and pickle bran and
add them together what would happen is
you get really murky kind of swamp water
and it kind of defeats the purpose of
both so buttermilk is an acidic cream or
you know dairy product that is to help
the chicken you know help it bread get
the coating on there and because it's
buttermilk and it's sour it kind of
helps ferment and add flavor to the
chicken itself and the pickle brine is
completely different where you're adding
a lot of salt content adding them
together I would suggest not you could
brine for a day and then
take it out put it in buttermilk for a
few hours but you really don't need to
do any of those things at Mike right 1k
I want to get my chicken wing dipped in
some mustard with a fruit roll-up
go yourself I don't even know what
you're talking about
waste of my time Thomas Sam after frying
food is there a way to recycle the
play-doh I hate wasting resources more
than anything especially food I have the
same problem I fill up a big pot I want
to fry like the fried chicken at home
what do I do with that oil let it cool
pass it through a coffee filter at home
just pour it through a coffee filter and
I save it and then I use that multiple
time probably four or five times until
it gets a little too gnarly and then and
then you have to throw it out next I
boat my float I made your fish on the
Dean today sadly my sauce split so I had
to fix it any advice on how to emulsify
a sauce if you have a pan sauce like
this it's really difficult to bring it
back once it is split as soon as you
start emulsifying though you take your
pan off of the heat you don't want to
emulsified sauce to boil if you're gonna
like monta something into it like throw
some butter into and monta stir what you
do you take it kind of off of the heat
and then you monta and then you put it
back onto the pit and you keep it warm
and you gotta play with it you got it
like stir and take it off and on and off
and on but even when making mayonnaise
if you see a mayonnaise is about split
you could add ice water ice water really
helps bringing things back it's a
stabilizer weird enough you're adding
something water to a oil-based dish
which is a stabilize I don't know the
secret it's all of them does that help
buddy I'm Roman Oh Patrick first time
successfully hanging a prosciutto
anything I can do with the 11 month old
bone
I would suggest making a soup at chef
Nick Valley what's the recommended time
at 10:00
gross pork belly you have at chef and
I'm just me
there's no chef in front of my name and
you're asking me kind of a funny
question you're roasting pork belly
right what are you gonna try to do with
that pork belly get you just want
roasted pork belly like there's so many
things that you could do you could roast
it to 145 degrees do you want a little
bit bite on it or do you want it to be
soft there's a lot of little weird
things that go into cooking pork belly
to begin with you're the chef I'm gonna
leave that one up to year there bozo
okay act carry Bao aha how do you feel
about broccoli broccoli is one of the
greatest vegetables in the world if your
foot gets eaten up by ants you can take
broccoli and rub broccoli and all your
ant bites and it will heal it do you
know that I'm you know the big problem
with rose gardens they always get in
black spots on the leaves if you take
broccoli and bury it in the ground next
to those rose bushes gone natural bug
repellent you're in the wilderness
you're getting eaten by mosquitoes
broccoli repellent natural repellent you
know all these what do you know look at
this guy fish I made your zesty fried
chicken how do I keep from burning boil
too hot well at Benjamin G Fisher let me
tell you something if you fried chicken
at 300 degrees Fahrenheit I'd say 12 to
15 minutes you were gonna have perfect
golden fried chicken every single time
if your shallow frying like maybe you
did here and you're using like a
cast-iron pan filled with oil what you
want to do is be on medium-high heat and
you still want to get your oil in the
pan around 300 but as soon as you add
fried chicken to that pan the
temperature will drop this is the hard
thing about cooking is that you have to
preemptively crank your oil if you're
gonna shallow
fry right before you add all of that
cooled chicken and if you crank it
wallets in there it may burn and then
your trick is wrong in the middle but
it's just about finding that sweet spot
47p that's the cost of my vegan lunch
but apparently that's too expensive to
people addicted to cheese and meat vegan
revolution let me tell you something
your food looks disgusting you got
canned beans and chopped up cucumbers on
white toast chill dawg
live your life at Dyer Andy question
what's the easiest way to DC -
pomegranate this is the fastest way
there you go how long did that take why
do people ask these question whose
laptop says needs a wipe at Brandon
Weiner
that's a good last name we nerd ranch
dressing question mark exactly your
question boy with wigs question warriors
punch marks are you serious I
would never eat chicken wings with ranch
dressing ranch dressing is disgusting
and should be illegal I'm an idiot for
not knowing how to properly cut a
pineapple you know first of all you
shouldn't shame yourself you're not an
idiot let's not use names so just cut
the top off really simply cut off the
bottom there you go and then what you do
is you take your knife and then you just
kind of cut along the edges and then you
want to make sure that you don't get any
of these like spiky things so then you
cut thinner ridges you just cut all the
way around and you just keep moving you
just cut away
cut away cut away there you go you got a
pineapple if you don't like the core you
can cut it in half just take your knife
like that like that take out that rough
core if you don't like that
now you got beautiful pineapple
there you go pineapple your man is a
half guy's my meat sledge look looks
like meat sludge bro you nailed it just
nailed it buddy
absolutely beautiful looks like a big
bald area god bless that last word
apparel a man isn't what would you add
to Y of rice to step up the flavor Abed
are these the questions that you are
pondering you weirdos throw your
dirty underwear in there give it
a stir and let me know how that tastes
at totally I'm at Madison what do you
think of spatchcock cooking a turkey
I know spatchcocking a turkey I think is
actually smart I think you know you got
a big bird you want the legs to cook the
same as the breasts flatten it out roast
it I think that's a really great idea
actually also Maddy hell in the hell so
you make garlic dipping sauce you'd save
me thousands of dollars in pizza orders
how much pizza are you ordering garlic
dipping sauce take garlic blend it up
add sour cream and some mayonnaise there
you go I think that's all you need to do
I really hope that I answered some of
your questions somewhere stupid
somewhere ridiculous but some were
thoughtful so I hope we found the middle
ground I hope we came together I hope
you learned a bit you know I haven't
learned a little bit
[Music]
you know keep tweeting me I love reading
this